[Music]
with magic tricks
i never done magic tricks before but i
am set
on absolutely making my wife go everyone
loves a good magic trick
it's the best and in this video i will
reveal
all the tricks that i've done but first
i have to learn how to do the tricks
the first trick is drop out brass this
is what i got this is what
was in the box is by mr magic
and it came with instructions uh it's
made in
india as you can see a plastic mold
black ass bottle
has a hole a steel ball in hole the ball
never out by the
performer if it down the ball never out
by the performer if it down
the ball never out by the performer if
it down
secret at that time down of the mold
steel ball comes inside index finger
when it opens guidance it becomes side
of the ball i'm even correcting it as
i'm reading it
what does this mean i spent 20 dollars
on this
after a few numbers of show performers
hand over audience to lock the ball
but they never but they never this is
gonna be disaster i know
it they know how how do i do this
[ __ ] trick
this does not twist so i looked online
there's one made by viking
here is small depression on the side
okay
it's called gravity yeah thanks a lot
there's something strange if there's
ringing down watch happens
i don't have a ring does it matter
yeah you've already shown the tricks
show me how to do it [ __ ]
why is it it must be magic all right
explain it then
they don't explain it they don't explain
the trick i'm screwed
i don't maybe i can figure it out i have
a big brain right do you press
is that it no this literally does not
move
when uh it opens the guidance it becomes
it comes upside the ball what does that
mean
thanks india 10 bucks for this garbage
no skill required [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you not even the comments can figure out
cool let's move on to the next trick
that was awesome thank you
next trick is even more awesome look at
this
we have the moon where is
it
there it is i'll explain this trick
after because it's so difficult
i can't wait to show this one to marzia
it also comes with the
instructions made in india very nice the
audience will not be impressed
that doesn't sound good the audience
will howl for the doors to be open
wow can't wait for that to happen all
right let's perform this one
the third magic trick is bingo that's
right
i'm supposed to do this trick where i
predict what martial put
it's the dumbest trick probably i've
ever seen and i i don't even need to
look up the instructions because it's so
stupid
but let's do it fourth trick i think
this one is gonna wow her
all right this one is a bunch of poker
chips and i'm gonna guess
which one marcia picks
basically it might be cool i think this
one is probably the best one
if this doesn't wow her uh we're out
we're outside
all right the final trick i'm supposed
to lock one of the cards
inside this device right the problem is
this is too
big it's supposed to fit a case
of cards i got like the shitty cards and
they don't fit
so i'm just gonna i'm just gonna have to
wing this one but hopefully
i it will wow marzia and the final item
is magic lighter where i'm supposed to
be able to
lit it with my mind which i can alright
let's see how it goes
are you ready for the greatest magic
show of all time sure
yeah trick number one because i actually
strict number two because i failed the
first one
if you don't howl during this magic
trick
i'm gonna be very disappointed what am i
looking at
as you can see nothing inside
yeah yeah as you can see
nothing inside yeah but if you
boom a sun
okay feel free to place it inside any of
them that you want
feel free to place it inside
[Applause]
so did i do the trick because when i
placed lady just rolled over
it wasn't even there before oh okay
okay i see okay where did it go martian
wait it's not in the back yeah it's not
at the back oh
oh time for the wow
[Music]
wow i haven't wait hold on
wow a magician never reveals his secret
it's magic
[Applause]
next up marxian we're going to play
bingo
yeah a game of bingo there's some gamer
bingo we're just going to play the game
bingo i'll be
cross that's not bingo
uh they call it bingo it's a taiwanese
game though they they cry
[Music]
it's cute where should i put there is
more magic happening
maybe magic maybe not magic
looks like you lost my idea yeah
yay i won all right let's do it again
boom my turn all right your turn
well stop stealing that [ __ ] all right
interesting okay
[Music]
oh interesting i know every move you're
going to make
marzia
[Music]
boom now why aren't you
yeah i have i'm going to really shock
you
because i've actually written down
the results
you ready for this
they're mirrored wow i guess this is the
only way
you start at first no no there's many
rooms
that's right the first time
[Music]
by the way i did match it just so we're
clear all right you don't
see it i got a cigar all right guys
yeah i think it was great either to be
honest the other one was
fun at least don't worry because i got
more tricks
not mercia take this and put it in your
pocket dude i did this on jack and jack
was so amazed
all right close your hand yeah yeah yeah
all right now wow now
right all right all right put your
finger in
flat one yeah
they add another one i don't like that
one pull that out
all right fair enough put it down
then shake it around again shuffle it it
doesn't matter it's not like being blue
yeah yeah don't worry don't worry
they move they move that's not the trick
if that's they definitely move by the
way
you can shuffle them as you want inside
if you want yeah
yeah and then do the next one put it out
we pick one up
okay place it on top of the other one
okay
fine do another one all right
all right and then do it one more time
put it out now
that's the one in your pocket
holy sh so what about the small pocket
huh no don't worry about smokey
what do you think of the tray well i
know you made me pick this one
you can't and then there were just but i
oh cause the last thing is the blue one
the last one was the blue one
oh that was the um yeah how did you do
it
i just named imagine a sorcerer never
reveals secret
all right cool how do i know guys do
they know
no i'll explain later but it's a really
cool trick
actually i picked it up but i did on
jack and jack was amazed like i
could tell amazing you're not really
amazed well if i
pick i did mess up the start i messed up
the start but it is
cool this trick is cool i like this
trick whoever made this you're cool
all right next trick for me
all right a card trick everyone loves
a good card drink right so
why don't you go ahead and pick a car
you can look at it don't tell it to me
but do write your name on it
yes
no i'm not looking at the mirror
all right give me the card i'm gonna put
it back
in the deck and then we're gonna shuffle
it
i'm not good at shuffling i'm trying my
best all right so
now what's gonna happen is you're gonna
pick the card from here
and you're gonna try and be as fast as
possible what do you mean
um i'm just looking for my own you're
looking for your own car you can look uh
up and down them or whatever too late
marzia i already have
your card
oh you just didn't put it in is this
your
is this yours yeah is this your card
go ahead and check this bolted tight
yeah
it's still tight how do i do that magic
baby
there's no magic or foul play there's a
real balance
how did i get it in there how did i get
you
all right don't you you look too closely
all right don't look so hard
i will i didn't think you were that
strong all right
well whatever
[Music]
that's my discard by the way how did i
do that
you didn't put it in here and you just
no
all right first of all this is
the thing is this is supposed to be
inside so i'm supposed to slide it out
like as i i'm supposed to like hold the
deck and then i'm supposed to like
it but since i didn't fit i had to like
kind of
do this meme but you didn't it kind of
worked the distraction to make you look
like
yeah oh that's yeah i'm amazed that this
worked
even closely all right you want us to
score
come on seven out of ten i got it bolted
in
all right then i'll pick a side come on
that's good that's magic baby how's this
magic show so far
seminar great
[Music]
[Applause]
why didn't you bring everything here and
i wanted you
to wear a cape you have to dress up for
me
okay hey can you figure out this trick i
don't understand
the thing is going to stay inside
is this it no what do you mean the thing
is going to stay inside
you can just give it to me i think i
broke this one
oh sorry did these just come like this
with no instructions
or anything yeah i actually came with
instructions
how am i supposed to figure these out
here
try and figure that out thank you
i don't get these but then again i'm not
a magician here
[Music]
what after a few numbers of shows the
performance handed over to the audience
to lock the ball
but they never
that was the magic show marzia i hope
you enjoy
[Applause]
thank you for tuning in oh my magic
and everybody what you're not impressed
i did like five of them
did you like the bingo one was bingo the
best no
i think i still don't know where the sun
went at the back all the magicians
okay i don't know but that one was cute
i like the prop and i still don't know
how you got the blue
on top so that's cool the blue the blue
chip
oh i can actually do that one again for
you if you want as little bonus
sure actually
i will explain that one because i think
that one is actually cool and magic
never
a magic sorcerer explains nothing yeah
like they don't do in india either
apparently this is the most hardcore
thing i've ever seen
okay thank you bye bye all right so
that's what we magician terms called
epic win
if you enjoyed video hit like subscribe
more video
hey though children of
nine parts it's time to raise what was
once forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean
you